thing sir have you broke have you spoken
to your brother since the interview
i haven't spoken yet but i will do and
can you just let me know is that the
royal family a racist family sir
i'm very much not a racist fan
uh well covering that our royal
correspondent rhiannon mills well he's i
think
uh the first uh major royal uh to
comment uh
on camera uh about uh what was said
uh by his brother and sister-in-law uh
what what did you make of it
yeah that's right so the other day
prince charles was actually the first
royal to be out about since
that interview aired over in america he
was thrown a question
about the interview dodged it didn't
want to talk about it
and i have to say in the past i've done
similar things thrown a question to
members of the royal family you don't
know whether or not they are going to
answer them but today i think
prince william they were very clear
questions that were asked by
my colleague insman rasheed that first
question have you spoken to your brother
i think the answer will surprise a few
people prince william saying there
no he hasn't spoken to prince harry yet
but he will do
but also that follow-up question are you
a racist
family and i think for prince william it
seems it was too hard
uh too toxic not to answer back and he
very clearly said
we are not a racist family now of course
that comes
after the queen issued that statement on
tuesday evening where she was very much
trying to bring this back to being a
private
family mata within that statement she
mentioned the word family
on three different occasions i think the
words in her statement were very
carefully chosen
making sure that she didn't downplay the
seriousness
of the claims that were being made
pointing particularly to the fact that
those issues were raised
over potential racism within members of
the royal family
and but also i think within the queen
statement that phrase that was so
telling and i think stands out for most
of us which was recollections
may vary so i think the queen was saying
then that actually they don't entirely
agree with everything
and that harry and megan have had to say
but certainly i've spoken to
people within the palace since that
statement came out and been told
very clearly they are not going to go
into any discussions
about the statement further they're not
going to go into any further discussions
about the interview they do not want to
see this
as a tit-for-tat battle between the
sussexes
and members of the royal family